foreign
intravenous drug user there's nothing
happy about it
they're really pushing their belief that
it's okay to use and it's fun to use
they've made it into a social justice
cause where it's an encouraged it's
encouraging use that is a line that
should have never been crossed
oh
we're not condoning drugs we're not
condemning it either we need to find
ways to empower and uplift our community
and trust me breaking down breaking them
down is is definitely it was not help
with that
[Music]
harm reduction was the black sheep of
the public health
um field you know like our approaches
was too radical for some folks but it's
been more accepted over the last few
years new approaches is needed we're not
condoning drug use we're seeing the
person we're seeing them
be you be you here take these supplies
and and you know the same people that we
give supplies to they come to us for
trainings they come to us for training
so and they come to us for jobs and all
of that and a lot of our Advocates come
from that background remember myself
included
and we just got we was given that chance
and that's what harm reduction is about
at this very moment on this very day
five years ago I was homeless on the
streets of the tenderloin in San
Francisco I was uh severely addicted to
heroin crack cocaine and Fentanyl and uh
I was just living a miserable existence
I got arrested a total of six times in a
three-month period in 2018 and if it
wasn't for the intervention that I
received out on the street by the police
and then the the love and compassion
that I received from the Salvation Army
who took me into their rehab center here
in San Francisco I would have never
found recovery and I wouldn't be where I
am today
the the harm reduction Mantra is that
you should have bodily autonomy you
should be in control of whatever you put
in your body including drugs and if
someone intervenes upon that they are
violating your civil liberties
so if you're in the privacy of your own
home I would kind of agree with that
what you do in your own home is really
your business so if you want to go home
in your house and smoke fentanyl all day
that's your business
but when you're doing it out on the
street in front of kids in front of
families in front of businesses harming
the business and causing harm to the
community
and then all the chaos that comes with
that the drug dealing the stealing to
support your addiction the violent acts
that can that can come out of let's say
extended methamphetamine use where you
fall into what they call meth-induced
psychosis where you think you're being
chased by helicopters and pretty soon a
guy's running down the street with an ax
which I have seen personally myself on
the street that
now you're violating other people's
civil liberties around you
and that's not okay and that's where the
harm reduction folks get it wrong and
that leaving someone in a tent on the
street to do whatever they want is
actually not body autonomy that's
actually cruel
I'm a drug and alcohol counselor I do
this for a living and the reason why I'm
against harm reduction is because it's
now changed to encouraging use
encouraging younger people to get high
these are impressionable people that
lack rational thought and critical
thinking there are aspects of harm
reduction that I embrace that I think we
need to consider especially around
overdose reversal uh needle exchange
programs we want to stop the spread of
blood-borne diseases like HIV and
hepatitis I get all that what we really
need to focus on in my opinion is
treatment and that's not necessarily
what harm reduction focuses on harm
reduction is all about well we need to
keep people alive so that they can find
treatment but they don't promote
treatment either and uh they've created
this kind of Perpetual cycle of
suffering
Department of Public Health in San
Francisco ran a campaign in 2020 talking
about knowing overdose and it had these
images of homeless people on the street
that had Smiles on their face that
looked happy they were getting ready to
stick a needle in their arm use with a
friend don't use a loan take small sips
or small doses it would have an image of
like some people at a party getting
ready to use drugs all smiles or or of a
group of homeless people on the street
that were getting ready to shoot dope
together right there out on the street
I've done that I was an intravenous drug
user there's nothing happy about it
folks think that we condone in drug use
one really we're like this is a reality
we're here to like help folks do it
safely to eliminate the transmission of
you know Aids HIV and other STIs and
other stuff you know we just want folks
to be safe so that they have tomorrow
you know and we don't know what tomorrow
brings I think a lot of people can wrap
their head around at least switching a
brand new needle because you don't want
to get you don't want to give someone
else your disease if you have it but
explain the rationale with hounding out
fentanyl straws fentanyl foil and pipes
that is insane you know uh we're seeing
these cute Valentine's cards and cartoon
characters in The fentanyl straws become
very colorful that look like candy canes
and it's very appealing to people that
are younger I mean this is what they're
doing is they're they're trying to
attract that younger generation it's no
different than how they marketed candy
cigarettes to kids in the 1980s and that
was eventually outlawed
we do that a lot out here too you know
like we do you know little fun stuff
with the with the pipe it's not once
again that we're promoting it but let me
once again these are people who don't
got nobody they don't got nobody and
they don't got nothing there's been
times I've done events and we pass out
Christmas cards with a pipe and a candy
cane um taped to it and you want to know
what they're like y'all doing the work
of God
and you think it's because we're giving
them those supplies they think that no
it's because nobody's looks at these
folks to have somebody you know give a
card and a chocolate Santa along with a
supply a stereo Supply that's going to
help them be safe they're not gonna they
know now for sure as long as they got
this pipe good and and it's and it's
good and and only they use it they ain't
gonna have HIV or hcv or any STIs or any
infections and you know they'll be able
to do their thing come Christmas that
same pipe or or or why everybody's
having fun which they is very much in
front of them because people who who's
losing drugs the people who we service
they sleep out in the streets so they
seeing families walk by with presents
and and coming out of restaurants and
all of that and what they just supposed
to cope with that Sobo
you know like there's a lot of ways we
could look at this but yeah we could be
punitive about it yeah we could nitpick
if we want yeah go ahead do you really
think that that messaging is gonna
uplift them it's gonna help uplift them
no it's not and that's what harm
reduction is trying to do we need to
find ways to empower and uplift our
community and trust me breaking down
breaking them down is is definitely it
would not help with that
we are dealing with the deadliest drug
in history
this is not marijuana this is fentanyl
50 times stronger than heroin and
cheaper this is insane
the best in harm reduction movement
could do is be like you know what we
hate fentanyl fentanyl sucks and we want
nothing to do with it and we will never
glorify it you know because it is
killing impressionable people and it
just sends this really terribly wrong
message that this is okay that we should
accept this as a society and that this
should become normalized and I will not
accept that the last like three years is
the worst I've ever seen you know this
is where they really believe this is a
revolution and this happened right
around when you know kind of the protest
started where you know everything just
became significantly more radicalized I
think this is this is bigger than even
harm reduction this is their social
justice movement where they feel like
this is really a revolution a revolution
of giving a person in a utopian World
everyone a right to do whatever they
want no rules no home ownership no
businesses in a completely socialistic
Society where you can basically just do
whatever you want that seems to be the
ultimate goal
[Music]
thank you